the force is what gives a Jedi his power
it's an energy field created by all
living things it surrounds us and
penetrates us it binds the Galaxy
together but the armed force for me is
the harmony that's in the universe that
that we're tapped into and where we're
kind of the keepers of it and we feel
the bad things that flow through it and
it's up to us to make sure we cleanse it
and do that and when we use it we use it
with reverence how can you say may the
force be with you be wearing I sense a
disturbance in the force a state of
being a state of being that once restful
and also poised and and also having a
sense of harmony with every living thing
and also every inanimate object as well
you must feel the force around you I
just think that the force is really you
know the main spiritual aspect of the
whole thing and going with your
intuition going with your feelings
because we really as humans are are
given something you know innate that
that we we have this knowledge of things
going on around us and what we should do
and and people don't trust their their
instincts enough and sometimes think
things through
too much you know I mean it's always
important to be - to think about things
but but sometimes your emotions or your
your most intelligent aspects
may the force be with us
[Music]
may the force be with us
yes Wow I cried when you said that I
can't imagine how you felt saying that
hey I have to say it was one of those
moments that I was really nervous hard
for weeks before and I kept just walking
around my house just trying out the line
so just be in the bathroom we like may
the force be with you
may the force be with you may the force
be with you you know that you go over
and over and over again because I knew
it was such a momentous moment for the
for the film I fear nothing all this as
the force will see I saw star wall back
in 1977 in Boston and that case later
and part of this and I mean and my lines
gets to see the coolest things may the
force be with you I am the force I fear
nothing for all this as the boss listen
I hope you can get take care you too
may the force be with you the force be
with us
may the force be with you
[Music]